bargain hunters will again be out in
force today fuelling what could be
record-breaking holiday shopping sprees
on the heels of a busy Black Friday
stores and malls saw high volumes
yesterday and what has traditionally
been the start of the pre Christmas rush
this year analysts predict holiday
spending will balloon to more than one
trillion dollars for the first time that
would be a five percent increase from
last year Kenneth Craig is tracking
these shopping trends this morning
Kenneth keep your credit card good
morning it's right Dana good morning to
you local vendors are hoping shoppers
keep up that holiday spirit today Small
Business Saturday is officially under
way in the National Retail Federation
says 67 million people will participate
that's after more than 100 million
turned out for Black Friday yesterday
it's become a hallowed ritual of
American consumerism we come every year
it's a tradition it's definitely hectic
it's good old-fashioned and family fun
and by mid morning yesterday Adobe
analytics data revealed consumers had
already spent 643 million dollars on
Black Friday sales MasterCard rejected a
23 billion dollar total windfall
although shoppers may have packed
brick-and-mortar retailers it seems the
viral stampedes of years past were not a
prominent fixture of yesterday's
shopping experience that says big
retailers offer online ordering with the
option of in-store pickups not to
mention an overall trend toward internet
purchases one report from consulting
firm Deloitte found 57 percent of
holiday spending will go through online
not in-store channels even so Black
Friday shopping was not devoid of drama
or violence police were on the scene in
Syracuse New York when two men were
stabbed inside one of America's largest
malls and in New Jersey last night
thousands evacuated a mall in Elizabeth
when a scuffle was capped off by gunfire
one man was hospitalized after he was
shot in the wrist we saw people running
and screaming and we heard like shots in
the background today local business
owners like Oklahoma resident Lisa
Miller are hoping to capitalize on the
Black Friday momentum with bar
Ekans of their own I think people truly
want to start shopping local again it's
just a time for us to shine and kind of
show what we're made of and let's not
forget that cyber monday is just two
days away nearly 76 million shoppers are
expected to take part in that day of
deals last year cyber monday was the
biggest online shopping day in US
history
hitting roughly 6.6 billion dollars it's
like the shopping yeah come on you guys
we cover this over and over and over
again does it really feel any different
it feels here well when you look at
these deals online I mean the deals
online are also amazing so you don't
have to go to the stores you can do it
right from your phone yeah my cyber
monday was cyber friday cyber saturday I
came home from traveling for
Thanksgiving and the lobby of my
building the packages were just so it's
rolling everywhere yeah it was like is
it Christmas already
it doesn't seem Bend you know Kenneth
great thanks so much here